si un homme qui tire une brouette avec
une fraise sur le siège et
comme son nom l'indique c'est l'homme
qui ramène sa fraise
c'est Georges Brassens a fait un peu
anarchiste sur les bords et je sais pas
c'est si c'est parce que j'étais comme
ça que je l'ai aimé ou si c'est pas ce
que je l'ai aimé que je suis devenu
comme ça
la scène se déroule à Bagdad en Irak
dans le viseur de ces manifestants
l'ambassade de Suède
une manifestation après l'autorisation à
Stockholm d'un nouveau rassemblement de
salwan Monica un homme de 37 ans
originaire d'Irak qui a fui son pays
pour la Suède et qui a déjà brûlé un
exemplaire du Coran le mois dernier
devant la plus grande mosquée de la
capitale suédoise avec l'été débute une
guerre d'un autre type baptisé Sun
bedwars la guerre des transats chaque
matin à l'ouverture des piscines d'hôtel
des vacanciers s'affrontent armés de
leur serviettes de plage leur objectif
réserver les meilleures places avant de
filer au petit déjeuner le phénomène
n'est pas né avec les réseaux sociaux
mais grâce à eux il est bien documenté
la liberté d'expression c'est très
important mais je pense que brûler un
ouvrage religieux ce n'est pas de la
liberté d'expression cette autre chose
c'est de la provocation
sur 10 sont favorables à l'interdiction
du burkini sur les plages c'est le
résultat donc
notre dernier sondages CSA pour cnews
lundi le Conseil d'État à suspendu
l'arrêter d'une commune du Sud-Est qui
interdisait le port du burkini à
Mandelieu-la-Napoule il est donc
désormais possible de le porter sur les
plages des migrants qui tombent de
prendre le large en plein jour au milieu
des enfants en stage de voile parmi eux
une famille avec un bébé croise le
regard d'une kayakistes c'est la scène
surréaliste à laquelle on assistait les
vacanciers mardi 2 jours plus tard cette
habitude de la plage n'en revient
toujours pas je l'ai vu révé le gros
zodiaque il fait cool juste après que
j'ai réalisé que c'était un bateau de
migrants forcément de voir ça mais
[Musique]
la fée verte comme on l'appelait et
réputé Céline pour ses effets
dévastateurs elle rendrait les gens fous
il est près de 10 heures ce mardi
lorsqu’un bateau taxi de passeur arrive
près de la plage pour embarquer une
cinquantaine de personnes face au grand
nombre certains sont repoussés et
terminent au milieu de la mer des images
choquantes qui marquent encore ces
moniteurs de voile
j'ai déjà vu pas mal de départs de
migrants aux alentours je sais que ça se
fait mais plus choqué du fait que ça se
passe ici finalement en pleine journée
où il y a du monde
ah tiens alors là ils sont dans les
paniers mais vous les vous les attrapez
vous les appâtez avec quoi avec des
pieds de vache des pieds de vache
ah mais oui dis donc c'est des pieds de
vache on va vraiment j'aurais tout vu
dans ma vie des pieds de vache avec le
sabot
la mer Méditerranée n'est pas la
souffrir des canicules des joints des
températures anormales sont apparues
dans les océans du globe aujourd'hui
44% d'entre eux subissent des vagues de
chaleur marines un record depuis 1991
l'Atlantique concentre toutes les
inquiétudes les scientifiques même n'en
reviennent pas mais
comment vous avez pu savoir que les
crabes à 100 mètres de fond émet les
pieds de vache
c'est l'expérience au fil des années
souvent dans la nature des pieds de
vaches à 100 mètres de fond non
voici la moyenne des anomalies de
température de l'Atlantique depuis 40
ans celle des trois dernières années et
voici en rouge 2023 les océans absorbent
90% de l'excès de chaleur causé par les
activités humaines la fusillade s'est
produite dans cet immeuble en
construction en plein centre ville
d'Auckland tôt ce matin un homme ouvre
le feu sur des ouvriers du chantier
suscitant l'effroi dépassant j'ai vu une
vingtaine de personnes sortirent en
courant de l'immeuble
je leur ai demandé ce qu'il se passait
ils m'ont répondu qu'ils avaient vu un
homme armé qui tirait sur toutes les
personnes qu'il croisait
la fièvre du football embrasse le stade
d'Auckland
37000 personnes à l'unisson coup d'envoi
de la 9e Coupe du Monde féminine qui
fait trembler les filets
c'est avec une profonde tristesse que je
peux confirmer que deux personnes ont
été tuées
de personnes ont été blessées dont des
policiers la police a également confirmé
que le tireur était mort les forces de
l'ordre estiment qu'il n'y a aucun
risque pour la sécurité nationale
pour convaincre les plus réticents que
le jeu des femmes n'a rien à envier à
celui des hommes ce clip il laisse
croire en truc quand les images que ce
sont les joueurs de l'équipe de France
qui réalisent ces actions spectaculaires
mais en réalité ce sont les femmes de
l'équipe de France
en 2021 dernière année de référence les
compétitions masculines représentées
74,2% des épreuves diffusées 21% pour
les compétitions mixtes et 4,8 pour le
sport féminin
ça pique à chaque fois que j'entends ce
chien après je me dis j'ai l'impression
qu'on régresse quand on voit qu'à
Barcelone il y a 4 ans et demi personne
dans les stades pour des matchs de Ligue
des Champions féminine c'est énorme en
Angleterre pareil pour des finales à
Wembley elle joue quand même à Wembley
devant un stade plein et ça on l'a pas
en France et on se demande encore
pourquoi nous n'avons pas ici en France
chez nous contre le cyclisme féminin
pour moi je vais vous dire voir Ulrich
myfaert faire du son en hauteur voir
evilage Ford faire du 100 m c'est très
joli c'est très joli à voir c'est un
très beau sport c'est un très non
laisse-moi terminé c'est extrêmement
beau à voir le sport doit avoir un côté
esthétique quand on enlève le côté
esthétique du sport il perd 50% si elle
veut le faire du vélo c'est leur
problème mais c'est pas le mien on m'a
demandé ce que j'en pensais
très très musclé et je pense qu'au
niveau d'une femme dans l'effort vous
vous êtes moches je suis désolé
admettons vous avez un joker c'est qui
Franck Gastambide
il y a un petit cœur il y a un petit air
mais
dans le taxi 5 en fait un moment donné
il y a un gros point sur lui il est je
crois qu'il est dans un bateau il tourne
la tête il fait un sourire
ciné
vous attaquez directement
le cyclisme féminin je crois que je
regarderai le cyclisme féminin le jour
où elle mettront des maillots un peu
plus jolis des des cuissards un peu plus
jolis et des chaussures un peu plus
jolie la succion des sangsues ne fait
pas de bien sur le moment mais vous
allez le voir elle va finir par soulager
Lisa une patiente atteinte
d'endométriose une maladie chronique qui
touche une femme sur 10 qui provoque des
douleurs insupportables et pour laquelle
on a longtemps cru qu'il n'y avait aucun
remède
[Musique]
tous tes gestes en douceur
le diriger
sensualité
vous stoppe un instant j'aimerais que ce
moment fixe pour des talents
[Musique]
parce que si vous voulez quand vous avez
mal quelque part elle le ressent parce
qu'il y a une chaleur plus importante à
un endroit
la franc-maçon alors j'ai un seuil
douloureux très très élevé
donc je ne sens absolument rien tu sens
toi
là je sens ça
c'est très désagréable des senti
médicinales